everyone this is Tom mcshay recording on
behalf of this so so sick Kevin menorah
we recently got to play an hour's worth
of Dragon Age Inquisition and talked to
producer Cameron Lee about how bioware's
upcoming role-playing game is developing
Bioware seems conscious of the many
negative reactions to dragon age 2 and
as a result Inquisition looks to be a
rather different kind of game where
Dragon Age tues environments felt
claustrophobic inquisitions are big and
immersive or dragon age 2 s exploration
was stunted inquisitions is expansive
the games third-person view is tighter
and more fluid than in previous Dragon
Age games and you now have a full range
of camera movement roaming the bucolic
area called the hinterlands and
Inquisition is rewarding as a result Lee
says that gaming's moved on from
neverwinter nights and Baldur's Gate and
the bioware is more concerned than ever
in keeping the player MURST in the world
to that end a single region in Incas
ition is as big as origin was and its
entirety yet you shouldn't assume the
Bioware wants to turn Dragon Age into
skyrim Inquisition still supports the
overhead tactical camera so many fans
want nevertheless Bioware focuses on
third person interaction in its demos
and battling creatures in this way feels
natural as a mage for instance you tap
buttons and fire off spells and quick
cooldown timers and dramatic magical
effects make it fun to fight
one of Inquisition species is that of
closing riffs that open in the sky and
allow creatures to pour through after
you fend off the enemies in the area you
close the rift by holding a button which
brings stability to the region and earns
renowned for you and your Inquisition
increasing the reach of your Inquisition
is important as your renown grows you
can return to the war table and command
Inquisition members to perform tasks out
in the world we got to fight a dragon in
the demo which focused more on combat
than on other elements of the game the
game was presented in easy mode so
unsurprisingly it wasn't a difficult
battle though it was nice to be able to
target the lizards various appendages
thanks to the localized damage system
least as a dragon age inquisition will
still present a great challenge of those
that want one and that skilful party
management is important in higher
difficulties if you don't want to get
slaughtered an hour isn't a whole lot of
time we're role-playing games are
concerned so we're still burning with
questions about dragon age inquisition
one of our favorite characters from
previous game has been up to now that
we'll be able to go to LA what's it like
there how much time will we spend in the
fade come October all these questions
will be answered when dragon age
inquisition is released and we're glad
that when it comes to some of the vital
details fire we're still keeping us
guessing
whatever we were before we are now the
Inquisition